[Music]
so I'm guy makan as I said I'm a
neurosurgeon at Columbia I one of the
things I get to do is I specialize in
awake brain surgery so I get to operate
on patients while we're looking at their
brain while they're awake while they're
functioning and the more you do that the
more you realize how little we
understand and actually know about the
brain so without further ado we're
really privileged today to have a
tremendous group of participants first
we've got our first guest is professor
of biomedical engineering and radiology
at Columbia University a member of the
Zuckerman mind brain behavior Institute
and Kathleen stitute for brain science
please welcome Elizabeth Hillman our
next participant is an assistant
professor of psychiatry neuroscience and
physiology at the NYU Langone Medical
Center who investigates the neural
circuitry of mating and aggression in
mice
please welcome dye you Lynne also
joining us is a neuroscientist and
psychiatrist at Weill Cornell Medical
College as a psychiatrist specializing
in the treatment of complex mood
disorders please say hello to Connor
listed on our file participant is a
neuroscientist director of Neuroscience
at Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory who is
interested in how brain circuits give
rise to behavior please welcome Tonys
aider
maybe first we could talk about a little
bit the history of where did
optogenetics come about from memory you
guys can talk about how you're using it
a little bit so interestingly actually
the history of optogenetics can be
traced back to an idea that Francis
Crick who's famous for the double
helical structure of DNA first came up
with he proposed that it would be really
convenient if we could activate neurons
with light he proposed that something
like 30 years ago
and it was people have tried different
approaches and were developing different
strategies for trying to make it work
and it was really the fortuitous
recognition that a protein from algae
could be expressed in neurons and endow
them with the ability to respond
immediately to to to light and that
happened I guess about a little over 10
years ago and it transformed how we do
neuroscience when I started in
neuroscience everything in terms of
trying to understand behavior was
correlational we saw neurons fire and we
saw the behavior and we put them
together and we we we of course all
recognized that correlation is not cause
a lady but with without the ability to
sort of dis excerpt that were
responsible for the behavior all we
could do is keep trying to find those
associations and so that happened about
I guess 2005 and within a couple years
lots of other lots of labs it happened
with it was a paper from Karl Deisseroth
and ed Boyden and within a couple years
dozens and soon hundreds of labs who are
using it so that that's really the the
basic history right so Connor you spent
time in the Ross lab before moving to
Cornell so tell us about how you've
gotten without the genetics to what
you're doing with it and some of the
potential applications as you see it
within your world yeah so as you guys
heard I'm a psychiatrist clinically and
one of the things that really excites me
about optogenetics is this potential
opportunity to understand the
neurobiological basis for men
health and mental illness and hopefully
develop new treatments and I think a big
limitation in psychiatry is that the
drugs we use I always like to emphasize
that the drugs we use they do work and
they've been a great benefit for a lot
of people but they're blunt tools they
bathe the brain and they they change
some aspects of brain function in a way
that that helps but they probably have
lots of other unintended side effects
and optogenetics affords us this really
unique opportunity to really precisely
manipulate specific brain circuits
figure out what's going wrong and and
try to fix it and that's that's one
thing that really excites me so give us
an example of how you've done that yeah
specific circuit that you've targeted
and what you've been able to find from
that yes so during my time at Stanford
this is like a collaborative work with
several other investigators there we
were really interested in understanding
how the brain supports reward seeking
behavior that's a thing that's obviously
altered in the brains of of many
depressed patients and we were able to
precisely manipulate the activity
patterns of specific cells in a region
of the brain called the prefrontal
cortex and begin to understand how how
it how it regulates the processing of of
reward related cues and motivates and
animals and presumably something similar
is happening in people's brains
motivates their their their desire to
work to obtain rewards and interestingly
what we found looks a lot like what what
goes wrong in the brains of depressed
people there's this abnormal pattern of
of increased connectivity in this brain
circuit and that seems to be driving
some of the the reward processing
deficits that these that these rats have
and possibly also people using so what
are you using it for and what types of
questions are you able to ask without
their genetics yeah so I was lucky
enough actually to be one not the first
person who benefits from the
optogenetics I remember it was a still
in the days when I was a postdoc and I
have to say
optogenetics although it's a new
technique but the concept of wise is is
not new in the sense that
neuroscientists that have tried very
hard for centuries are trying to
manipulate to the brains in order to see
will happen so but the conventional
manipulation is bypassing some currents
into the brain so the electrical
stimulation and that's where I started
and when I trying to study the brain
before the optogenetic era electrical
stimulation there is a1 deficits of that
which is that neurons they're not just a
cell which are ball but they actually
have a lot of processes coming out so
when we electrically stimulate it we're
not only stimulated the cell body this
ball but also all the processes coming
from it so potentially the cells which
is a far away can also be activated
because of this electrical stimulation
and optogenetics is advantageous because
it allows you to really target the cells
are interesting without affecting those
cells are just the sending processes to
it that's the specificity that makes it
is to really unique and now we're
putting up the genetics into those cells
and a stimulate so why don't we look at
if we have the aggression video so this
is a mouse there was this part of the
brain it's a very deep very ventral and
we turn down this area and you'll see
that he start to attack this cloth and
he really you know that's not what Mouse
typically do so they don't usually
attack a glove so but in this particular
case when the lighter activated you
repeatedly sink his teeth into this
glove in fact when we take it out this
glove is in fact a deflated so and it's
not only gloves in fact they will attack
other con specifics including a female
Mouse that a male will typically would
not attack at all
so this animated object probably shows
the extreme of this behaviors
that this control of this areas just
turn on this attacking instinct
immediately there's some specificity to
the aggression it does it does in fact a
one of the big questions we are trying
to ask in the lab is when we do activate
this area is this just the abiding
events oh it's actually increasing this
aggressive motivation of the animals and
that's why we're designing different
Aviva tasks in order to dissociate at
this part but that's exactly trying to
ask is it to just make them bite oh
actually they are become has this urge
to a class a cat all of you guys are
talking about technique where you're
able to select out a very small specific
part of the brain to try to isolate and
look for behaviors Elizabeth you've been
focusing on the one hand on using
imaging techniques to look at much
broader patterns of activity and and
larger connectivity patterns between the
brain and even whole brain activity and
various types of animals can you fill us
in on some of the things you've been
doing along those lines
well so we we did a lot of technique
development in the lab and I was trained
as a physicist so I did a lot of optics
and and so you know these technologies
when they come along they don't just
come along wonderful people conceive of
them and piece them together but then
using them and figuring out how to do
that is is really challenging as well
and that's a really important factor
here so the little mouse had a thing on
its head and that was actually holding
an optical fiber that was allowing you
to put laser light into the actual brain
to turn these cells on and off and so in
an hour we're really interested in you
know how can you how can you do that
better I mean it's not just that you can
turn cells on but you can actually turn
cells off as well and the dream is to
have many many different colors so that
you can be very selectively turning one
thing on and turning one thing off and
that really lets you you know figure out
what part each one of those things is
playing I was thinking of the analogy of
sort of what is my role in getting my
kids out of the house in the morning
right well how do you tell that do you
just throw me in there and make me flash
no but if you take me away and
see what happens when I'm not there you
know it's quite quite helpful way of
figuring out what it is exactly but so
figuring all of this out I mean for me
you know we do our own we do our own
experiments as well and I will talk
about that more but but figuring out you
know working working with you guys you
know what what exactly experiment do you
want to do what behavior do you want to
do now which areas of the brain do we
have to get to and how do we have to
make that all work together so that we
don't have to have ten lasers and all of
this stuff happening at the same time is
is one of the things that really gets me
going and then and then and then we
combine that with imaging because you
know what you've seen mostly there is is
the readout you know you change
something in the brain and you look at
the way that the person's actions change
or the animal's actions change but we
can also simultaneously be looking at
what effect that has then on the firing
of the other neurons and so we do a lot
of work trying to capture activity at
the level of a few cells at the level of
the whole brain we look at that activity
in in flies and and worms and and little
fish and then we also do it up at the
scale of mice and then sort of project
that up to the scale of the human brain
also so it's very different from
exciting a few neurons with one fibre
you're looking at what the brain is
doing spontaneously in its own so what
you're seeing here is actually that the
entire top surface of a mouse's brain
and that reveals a whole ton of
different areas of the brain that we can
look at all at the same time
we're using something called gcamp which
is a calcium sensitive fluorescent
protein so what we were just talking
about was optogenetics where you express
based on the genetics of the cell you
make the cell produce this
light-sensitive protein and one of the
other major tools that has really
revolutionized neuroscience in the last
five to ten years has been these
fluorescent proteins like the glowing
jellyfish that you've probably seen or
the newspapers with the glowing mice
right so these are calcium sensitive
fluorophores which means that actually
when the neurons fire they look that
they actually flash and we can read that
out okay so it's sort of the opposite so
we've been observing this in the mice
and we've found these amazing patterns
of spontaneous activity that tick around
in the brain and what I thought be fun
to show you today is that we do a lot of
quantitative analysis on this trying to
understand the cadence of these patterns
and the locations of these patterns and
what do they mean and one of the things
that we just were able to do if you go
to the next slide so we we found that
again it's hard to see with these
patents so on the top left is is just a
still of these kind of weird patterns of
activity that we really see coursing
through the whole brain and we found
that they were sort of coming on and off
in different regions of the brain and so
I'm gonna play a movie here where what
we've done is rather than just showing
you the movie of these patterns that
seem to kind of roll around in the brain
because there's different regions that
are lighting up one after the other
we've actually encoded them in color and
also as notes on a piano so what you're
going to hear is kind of what it sounds
like in the brain of a mouse as a mouse
is just sitting there resting and this
is over pretty much the entire surface
of the brain so all the regions
responsible for seeing and hearing and
motor actions this was all done by my
student Nick here who is a biomedical
engineer slash composer so if you want
to just click the I'm not kidding there
you go every time it region lights up
you hear a note give it a say
[Music]
so we use this method just as a way to
try to just really capture is the
relationship between the brain activity
and the music fully automated or is
there yes this is actually using the nmf
non non-negative matrix factorization
algorithm on this data and then taking
the factors and then putting them into
musical notes and then if you go to the
next slide so then Tony Tony was saying
before the at rest at least based on the
music pattern and mice are quite calm
well after I started doing this analysis
I I remember I had a big grant on this
that I submitted right before
Thanksgiving and I was sitting there and
Thanksgiving and I was I just kept
feeling this rhythm of my brain you know
and thinking you know if I could just
sort of calm down watch some television
if I just watch you know ten Things I
Hate About You one more time maybe I get
myself into this state you know what I
mean and and so this drew us on to the
to the next part which is we then gave
the animal caffeine okay go to the next
slide and play the movie on the left so
it's it's not so different it's a little
faster has some gaps okay and then so we
gave it an ketamine
so ketamine is a is a drug some people
use it recreationally and they shouldn't
and it's an anesthetic which really
makes you basically unconscious makes
you high has various effects of making
you forget and so on so that's the one
on the right here and you'll see it has
a really profound effect what's what's
really interesting about this is it you
know it's this is a very odd modality
that we came up whether we actually just
take the state to using LEDs and cameras
it's it's it's very low-key compared to
the really high-tech stuff that we also
do in lab but the reason why I'm really
excited about this is I think
neuroscience for a long time has zoomed
really far in on just just the cells you
know looking at single cells and how
does
interact with each other and when we
discovered this activity that's really
everywhere it really changes the way
that I'm now trying to think about you
know the brain is just sort of talking
to it's like the internet right it's
it's not just you and you sitting there
it's you connected to all your Facebook
friends and all of those things kind of
interacting together and so we're just
um we're having fun with this of course
but we're really using this now to try
to understand how that's sort of the
whole brain and contributes to behavior
and particularly here we're thinking
about state so a state of being anxious
a state of being calm and and really
what does that look like and then how
was each one of these react differently
if you presented it with an aggressive
glove you know you're showing these
amazing patterns of how the brain
connects and what connects to what you
know Tony you've taken a totally
different approach to try to study major
areas and how the what actually connects
to what and how we unravel that maybe
can you can you explain that for us yeah
so sort of to put in perspective when
there's when the optogenetics revolution
hit my lab jumped in whole-hog we were
already training mice or at that time
rats to perform what we thought were
cognitive tasks and we could talk more
about that but we were training them to
listen to sounds and make decisions
based on the sounds they heard to get
rewards and we were trying to understand
the circuits that were involved in
making those decisions and we had
identified certain subsets of neural
using optogenetics later we'd gone
beyond simply recording the activity of
these neurons and actually shown that
one set of neurons turns out that
projector the auditory straight and were
actually really important in carrying
information about a sound toward driving
movement but what I realized from that
was that you know we can make guesses
about the circuits involved and using
optogenetics we can actually test
whether our guesses are right for the
first time like we could test at the
circuit level well which subset of
neurons within a particular area are
driving this behavior versus that
behavior and what roles they play but
the prowl
was that we we just had to make educated
guesses and one of my students was
really fantastic and made a really
educated guess and and guessed right and
and showed this this particular pathway
but other students made less successful
guesses and the cost of guessing wrong
is a couple years of work you you do a
set of experiments and if you guessed
wrong the answer is nope I have Todd
that wasn't the right guess and you
learn very little and career there used
to tell people I still tell them who
entered my lab I quote from Shrek always
there's a there's a for those of you
might my son at that when he was younger
watched Shrek over and over again and
there's a scene where Lord Farquhar
sends his Knights out to find the
princess and he says this mission is
dangerous many of you may die but that's
a risk I'm prepared to take come up
empty-handed so anyway how did you make
it better so the so the idea was that we
needed a way to to screen through the
guesses we needed to know what the
circuit was in order to know what was a
reasonable guess it knowing the circuit
would not tell us how it actually works
but it would rule out all sorts of
possibilities and the problem was that
the tools that were available were
either not high enough resolution didn't
have single neuron resolution or they
were incredibly slow so that what we
needed to know was whether there are
neurons let's say in mike is in the
auditory cortex that send their axons to
this region and that region and whether
there are other neurons that send their
neurons here and there and the problem
was there was no way of knowing in sort
of a high-throughput way what the
millions and billions of neurons well
millions and emmaus billions in a human
where they send their axons and so the
traditional methods for asking those
questions were all based on microscopy
the typical high resolution method is to
take one neuron in one animal fill it
with a with a fluorescent tracer or some
other kind of tracer and then track that
trace all throughout the brain the
problem is you know one neuron per Mouse
lots of neurons that's very slow if you
try to do more than one neuron the
problem is that the that the processes
start overlapping and you can't resolve
where the individual processes from
these neurons go and so the idea that I
had eight years ago now but it's finally
working was to replace the usual way of
visualizing the neurons which is just to
look at a fluorescent dye with what has
turned out to be a fantastic marker
which is DNA or in fact RNA so what we
do is we we cause each neuron to express
a unique random sequence of RNA which
then gets transported all throughout the
cell so how do you do that why does a
neuron walk so real neural RNA
yeah and in real life most neurons do
not express random in general you don't
have a lot of random labels floating
around your body in fact the only case
in our body that we know of where we
have random labels is your immune system
where the genetic material gets
scrambled each time to make antibodies
so we thought about actually trying and
we're still kind of working on trying to
trick neurons into scrambling their DNA
but an easier way to do that is we can
make viruses that are that each express
a unique random 30 nucleotide 30 letter
string of DNA and then we just squirt
that into the brain and each neuron
takes up one viral particle sometimes
they take up two and we could talk about
technically whether it's it's not a
really a problem and then those that it
gets amplified within the neuron and
gets transported out to the axon so now
we no longer have to carefully trace
each little process we can just use DNA
sequencing technology where
has transformed other fields of biology
we can just just piggyback off of these
tremendous advances and DNA sequencing
technology which have driven the price
of sequencing our genome down to below a
thousand bucks we can we can use
literally that same technology to figure
out where all these neurons project so
every neuron has its owns its own
individual every neuron has its own
individual label and it's actually I
should have shown this picture it's
inspired actually by an idea that
scientists at Harvard Josh Saenz and
Jeff Lichtman came up with about 10
years ago called brain bow where they
cause each neuron to express not one
color but a rainbow of colors and so
basically the idea is to replace a
rainbow of colors it's hard to read out
more than a couple of colors so there
wasn't such a big win but it makes
beautiful pictures to replace those with
these sequences and so now what we do is
we inject in to one side in the brain or
in fact we can now tile the entire brain
with this virus and figure out where all
the neurons in the cortex projective so
in fact I was looking at your pictures
and one of the we're just now starting
to analyze this whole brain connectivity
map and it turns out that there are sort
of communities of neurons that talk
preferentially to each other and in fact
the the communities that we find based
on these connectivity actually are very
reminiscent of the sort of different
cords especially in the ketamine brain
where it looks like there's they're sort
of within a community there's a lot of
conversation then it passes the message
to the next community so it's possible
that you may be seeing with nerve axon
or labeling some of the same I think I
think actually the substrate for what
you're seeing is precisely we should
hang out yeah so how do you so how do
you take that to the next a different
level and say now we know how things all
communicate how do you start studying
what's normal and what's Admiral right
so so the the the the idea here is that
we can now for a couple thousand bucks
figure out the whole connectivity of a
brain there are some issues about
resolution it
single neuron resolution but the spatial
resolution is limited we have some ideas
and actually we're working on methods
that give you higher resolution but the
real interesting idea is that we we can
now compare the wiring diagram of a
normal Mouse to a mouse that has a
genetic deficit that has been associated
with a human disease and there are now
dozens or hundreds of these mice these
so called animal models of autism and
schizophrenia and depression so we know
that that there are genes that cause
that are associated with human
conditions we know that when you put
those when you disrupt those genes in
mice they disrupt behavior in ways that
are sometimes similar sometimes not but
we in many cases we think that what's
going on is that disruption of those
genes causes some kind of change in the
neural circuit but once again the
traditional approach to figuring out
what that change is is to take an
educated guess burn up a couple of grad
students and if you guessed right
then well but that it that is how these
things go it's it's incredibly
frustrating and so the idea is now we
can we can actually take one of these
mice and say look here is the disruption
we're not sure which of these
disruptions are causal in the behavior
but this totally sort of constrains the
set of hypotheses that now physiologist
like me and the other people on this
stage have to consider so you're taking
a lot of the guesswork for the grad
students out of picking a project that's
right that's right that's really my goal
is to sacrifice fewer grad students on
the altar of bad guesses which is very
we would all agree Conor Conor you've
taken a different approach to try to
look at populations of neurons by
putting little prisms in the brain and
combining it with optogenetics King can
you talk about that and what it allows
you to do that's different from
traditional opto genetics yeah so this
work is really similar to what Elizabeth
was just describing but it's kind of on
a more microscopic scale so we're using
the same kind of calcium sensors that
that fluoresce in proportion to their
activity like you saw most beautiful
videos that Elizabeth showed us a few
minutes ago but we are looking with
single cell precision on a much smaller
area of the brain one of the functions
that we're really interested in is
working memory this this basic kind of
fundamental form of short-term memory
that we all use all the time like if we
decided we wanted to take a break now
and order some pizza working memory is
like what would enable us to kind of
look up our favorite pizza place on your
phone and store the memory of the phone
number are long enough to dial it but it
goes away rapidly and teamwork and and
it's disrupted in depression and in
schizophrenia and in many other
psychiatric conditions in different and
interesting ways so we think it's kind
of a fundamental process we could show
that video yeah that video so so what
you're seeing here are cells in the
prefrontal cortex those black those
blacks kind of bands are blood vessels
but these are individual neurons brain
cells that are expressing this this
fluorescent calcium sensor and that
starry night effect is is basically a a
readout of how active each one of these
cells is over time and what you what you
don't see is that this mouse is awake
and it's behaving it's performing a
working memory task while we're getting
this this readout and so what we hope to
be able to do is test hypotheses about
how particular cell types in this image
that you're seeing here how they
interact to encode and maintain a trace
of the working memory during a delay
period during the time it would take us
to dial the phone number in that analogy
and how these different cell types
interact to kind of imbue working memory
with with interesting properties and
then once we understand that like like
we were just discussing a minute ago we
can we can formulate hypotheses guesses
and actually
test them using optogenetics to
manipulate the activity of specific cell
types and test whether our predictions
are actually true or not so everybody
here is using different animal models to
study these things to try to come up
with information that can help us
fundamentally understand human behavior
so maybe as a group whoever wants to can
talk a little bit about about how do we
best do that how do we best do that in a
way that we are you know minimizing use
of animals being compassionate in that
you know but yet understanding what we
need to understand so what are your guys
thoughts on that we recently started
using fruit flies and I don't feel bad
about that at all what can you learn the
beauty of the fruit fly model is that
you can breed them really really quick
and so these genetic techniques now that
are really the core of neuroscience that
let us label these cells different
colors and change them introduce genetic
diseases make them up express up to
genetic channelrhodopsins you can do
that in the space of a week you can just
cross two flies and and then you have
another fly and it's got rainbows in its
brain and it doesn't have this stuff for
me what's really nice because I when I
build microscopes what you show what you
saw there was a about a 10 millimeter
field of view which is what we needed
but we couldn't see single cells but if
you if you have a fly's brain we can fit
that whole thing within our microscopes
field of view and so we can see every
single cell in the entire brain and so
we do these completely crazy things
where we get the fly and we actually
have it walking on a ball and we're
imaging its whole brain while it's on a
ball and then you can actually puff
odors and and and odors of Lady flies
and then you can see what it does and
you can see where it crawls and then
you're seeing all of this activity in
the brain you know as it's doing that
and so our flies the same as humans
probably not I mean they can fly which
we can't so I don't know but what we're
trying to do on so many different levels
is understand building blocks understand
basic principles understand
you know how does behavior emerge from
all of these little cells flashing on
and off and so doing it in that system
is a is a very efficient very good nice
way of understanding something at that
level and then scaling it up so there's
there's people in neuroscience working
at every single level what we really
need to do is all talk to each other and
and sort of piece together all of those
clues and we also do the maggots as well
I mean it's it's gross that diet you you
you you work on aggression but you also
work on maternal instincts so another
thing that's across the animal kingdom
but that we all think of it as an
incredibly human thing but obviously
it's it's it's it's much across the
animal kingdom so maybe you could talk
to us about how you study
that sort of thing with something like
that yeah
they are my views a lot of social
behaviors instinctive behaviors that
they're all controlled by those Asian
structures that the mechanisms very
conserved and the the maternal and the
paternal behaviors in fact a parental
behaviors in general in fact is also
highly sexual dimorphism and one of the
regions we study is controlling the
maternal behaviors so like to show you a
video here just to say that we're not
only looking at the behaviors which is a
fighting but also this like just a
heartwarming video so when you look at
it so this mouse this is a virgin female
that they she doesn't really care about
it a pups so much and she doesn't have
much experience with the pups so this is
a called a sham sham stimulation
basically no stimulation with just the
Indus areas then we put in a puppy in
the corner and she basically the nor the
pups that the pups is or whipping around
and probably making any bit sana trying
to get her attention and so so this
partner will be 60 seconds which I guess
we're just trying to convince you that
there's really nothing happens so now
pay attention so now we start to
stimulate to just part of the brain
right here and then she'll walk the
right out and I bring the path back home
so so they are part of the brain regions
which really just
taurine dose and maternal instinct and
when it turns out they should become
instant mom and do this all day long
yeah so before we move cuz a lot of you
guys are doing not just mouse modeling
but also doing human work too can you
all comment on because because I don't
know if anyone here is actually working
with it in addition optogenetics you're
out of the Dicer off lab another great
development has been this technique
clarity the ability to take the brain
which is an oblique structure and
essentially turn it into a windowpane so
can you all talk about how you see that
as a tool the strength of it and can you
potentially merge it with some of these
other techniques well I think that so
for those of you who haven't heard
there's a technique that allows so we'd
like to see where all the neurons are
we'd like to see how they're all
connected and what limits it is the fact
that the neurons are embedded in all
sorts of fab and extracellular stuff and
when you do microscopy it's very
difficult to see clearly what's going on
and so for several decades people have
been trying various methods for clearing
tissue for making it transparent and
there have been a couple of major
advances in the last couple of years
including the clarity technique from
DICE Roth's lab and some other
techniques that have made it much easier
to see a lot of the brain clearly to be
able to image down one to three
millimeters in fact as the limits now of
less to do with the actual tissue and
more to do with microscopy I think that
that really is making it a lot easier to
quickly see what the circuitry is how
different parts of the brain are
connected where we're using sort of
related techniques in fact we're using a
technique developed by a guy named ed
Boyden at MIT which in some sense goes
one step further it allows you to not
only clear the
the tissue but simultaneously to expand
it so some of the structures were
interested in it's called expansion
microscopy surprisingly enough so some
of the structures we're interested in
are below the resolution of light and
the usual approach to resolving a
structure that's below the resolution of
visible light is to use electron
microscopy which is a lot of work my
grad students it's more it's it's a it's
a million-dollar machine and just that's
it's it's a nightmare
at least on this scale for c4 for
applying electron microscopy to sort of
macroscopic structures and so what he
had I mean ed is actually the
[Music]
co-developer of channelrhodopsin along
with Carl dice Roth what Edie realized
was that instead of getting making
microscopy better so you could see
smaller things it would be just as good
is if you could make the smaller things
bigger and so he developed a technique
that was really that was inspired by and
actually uses literally the stuff that
they make diapers out of and you know
how you for those of you who are
familiar with diapers you add liquid
we'll say water to a diaper and it
expands and so he embeds this this this
diaper stuff in between the bits of of
neuron and then binds every little
protein to a bit of it and then expands
every protein isotopically in all
directions and so you can get expansion
factors that are 2 & 4 and now even 20
times the original so you can take a
synapse which is below the resolution of
light point below point 2 microns and
make it a 3 micron 5 micron structure
which we can easily resolve and I think
that that technique is is really on the
verge of transforming a lot of what we
can do and can you merge that so we are
we are actively working with Ed's lab to
merge our approach so all of this is to
be clear is in
you know fix tissue and tissue from the
brain after it's out of the skull so the
optogenetics is fantastic for working
with a live animal but then to figure
out the circuitry of that animal that
what you have to do is take it out and
then use one of these methods so we are
barcoding neurons in all the animals you
know we're getting ready to perform a
task and then we expand the tissue and
do the sequencing in situ so we can
actually sequence the barcodes while the
barcodes are still inside the brain and
it gives us the spatial resolution to
actually see which barcodes are out of
synapse and actually figure out which
neurons are connected to which other
neurons so there's there are some
engineering issues throughputs but
throughput issues but conceptually we
can expand an entire brain and figure
out the wiring diagram of an entire
brain at synaptic resolution and while
we're at it we can also figure out which
genes are being expressed so this is you
know one of one of the people and Ed's
lab calls it the Rosetta project because
basically we can figure out everything
about a brain all the way from activity
while the animal is performing a task
the behavior and then the circuitry and
gene expression that caused those things
so that that's where we're hoping to go
with them that's pretty amazing to think
about so but as you say that's finding
out everything about a mouse brain yeah
and so we're talking a lot about you
know do mouse mice have human behaviors
and things you know Elizabeth can you
talk a little bit about you've been a
very strong proponent of that we've
already got great human imaging
techniques that you're you're using but
also in humans and trying to trying to
study the differences in similarities
and what we can gain more out of our MRI
techniques we already have and how
you're going about that and helping
translate ideas sure so so I touched on
this a little bit before but I use
anybody here had an MRI scan yeah have
you have you ever volunteered for a MRI
scan where they
you had to do tasks and things like this
okay so I've done lots of them they're
very I fall asleep I'm terrible subject
so we so the you go into an MRI scanner
it makes this beautiful image of your
brain and what they discovered about 30
years ago now is if you actually took a
sequence of images over time that you
could see small changes in the signal in
different regions of the brain while you
were doing things so like if you
actually moved your hand you could find
a region of the brain that would have
some sort of correlated change in the
MRI signal while you were doing that
task and we call that the bold signal
the blood oxygen level dependent signal
and it's what generates those beautiful
movies images that you see on the front
of the New York Times saying this is the
area of the human brain that reacts when
you see a picture of a puppy or
something and and so you know I didn't
my I did my postdoc up in Boston in one
of the centers that actually developed
this method and so right now you know
this is the best method that we have for
looking at the human brain it it's
non-invasive any one of you can go sit
and do one of these studies and pretend
to be a mouse you know tapping your
fingers are being shown pictures and and
it does a pretty good job it points to
this area here this something happened
here right the problem is that that
signal actually comes about because
there was a change in blood flow in that
area so there's not really a change in
the MRI signal when a neuron fires but
there's a change in the magnetic
properties of blood when it becomes
oxygenated or deoxygenated and so that
little signal change that you see is
actually coming from a change in blood
flow to the area and that's why it gets
a little bit confusing because it's a
little slower than the neural activity
because it takes a while for blood flow
to change after neuro neurons fire and
so I've spent in addition to the the
other work I've done I spent a long time
studying this the relationship between
neural activity in the brain and the
blood flow activity that that kind of
accompanies it partly initially to help
with understanding those fMRI images
better functional MRI because we knew
using blood but we wanted to understand
what that meant in terms of neurons
I could talk about this all day but it
chords caused us to have to develop a
lot of imaging methods to go in and use
microscopes to simultaneously look at
neurons firing and blood vessels next to
them and I got very interested in it
from the standpoint of it's actually
quite surprising that every time a
region of your brain has some neural
activity that there's actually a big
increase in blood flow in that area and
that has to happen for a reason and
there has to be an important part of
brain health and so now my work has sort
of moved towards not just trying to
understand the fMRI signal better but
also recognizing that there might be
situations in which that relationship
between neural activity and blood flow
gets disrupted and if every time you're
hungry you try to eat a sandwich but you
miss something's gonna happen you're
gonna lose weight you're not going to
perform as well and so what all that
stuff I showed you with the coffee and
the ketamine they're really the core of
that study in the beginning was looking
at how that neural activity actually was
coupled to blood flow changes and we've
got ways now we actually can give drugs
that disrupt the relationship between
neural activity in blood flow and we can
then see what effects do they actually
have in real time on neural activity
what effects they have on behavior so
we're training the animals to sit and
actually push a lever this is one of
Nick's other projects right flick their
whisker try and get them to push a lever
disrupt this blood flow relationship and
see whether they actually become slower
at pushing the lever simply because this
is just another aspect of the brain that
we really don't understand
stepping back if we can get a better
handle on this relationship between
blood flow and neural activity it gives
us a way to really better use functional
MRI and it has this method it has kind
of an image problem right we all agree
because it's not so clear what it means
and in fact when you do it in someone
who just had a stroke you might see huge
activity in an area where they're
paralyzed or you might see no activity
at all and they go on to be to have a
great recovery and so sort of my mission
is to to use these methods more in the
mice where we can do this very detail
imaging but to try to disambiguate all
of this try to find is there an early
signature of Alzheimer's is there
something that happens in stroke that we
can actually understand in terms of what
it's going to look like in fMRI and then
can we use fMRI and much more guided way
to get to those conditions in human
brain so it's a little sounds a little
circuitous but it keeps me busy I think
we all agree it's something there's a
huge need for you know to understand
what is it we're seeing and how do we
learn from it you know car you've done
some of the same thing and trying to
tease apart subtypes of depression using
using functional imaging can you tell us
kind of how you've approached that and
what you've found and what you think the
potential for that kind of analysis is
yeah yeah we're really excited about
this is another area we're really
excited about in my lab the the
opportunity to potentially use brain
imaging to rethink the way we diagnose
psychiatry if you make diagnoses in
psychiatry if you'll bear with me for
like two minutes I'll tell you an
interesting historical Dyk like little
background story so our DSM this book
that we use for diagnosis it's kind of
seeped into the public lexicon right you
read about and the times a lot of people
are familiar with it and the whole way
we diagnose mental illness is really not
very old it was completely changed in
1980 I was born in 1980 you can't say
that about very many other areas of
Medicine and and yet and yeah it's the
truth everything we do in psychiatry is
quite different from before 1980 due in
part to this kind of controversial study
that was published in science seven
years before that just showed
essentially that our our diagnostic
system at that time was not very
reproducible and very prone to bias so a
social psychologist at Stanford very
cleverly designed a set of experiments
where he sent his investigators into
hospitals around the country presenting
with a a fake symptom they were they
said I'm experiencing voices saying the
words empty hollow or thud and otherwise
they were supposed to answer all
questions honestly truthfully and and
the results they just followed them and
the results really shocking to everybody
they got different diagnoses in
different places later work showed that
your socio-economic background and your
ethnic
background were could bias the way
people assigned diagnosis to you and and
it was really hard to detect that these
were fake patients basically that's
that's what he showed you could bias
people's judgement in that way and then
in a second part of the study and this
is kind of the clincher in the second
part of the study he the the Leda on
this study had met the director of a
famous hospital at the time and he said
you know this is this is an anomaly what
you found is not representative of the
way we do business come to my hospital
see if you see if you'll get different
results and so they agreed he would send
an unknown number of people into his
hospital over the next few months and
during that time their job was to figure
out who is a fake patient who's a real
patient twenty percent of people were
identified as definite imposters another
twenty percent were identified as
probable imposters so fully two out of
every five people who came to the
hospital had were thought to be possible
imposters and the truth was that he
hadn't sent any Impostors and they were
all real patients so you could bias
people's judgments in both ways and so
getting to the point here the DSM 3
which was released in 1980 and very
similar to the one we use today was
really designed to lump lots of people
together with very different problems in
big diagnostic categories that we could
all agree on and and it did a really
good job of that the the diagnoses are
much more reproducible than they used to
be less prone to bias but the problem is
they don't correspond in biology very
well so depression is a great example of
that you have this like choose five or
more of nine symptoms so there's at
least 256 ways you can be depressed and
some of them are almost opposites of one
another like sleeping 19 hours a day
can't get out of bed not enjoying any
activities very slowed gained a lot of
weight that person's depressed so as a
person who is sleeping three hours a day
anxious weight loss almost the opposite
and they get the same diagnosis but they
probably don't have the same biological
problem and it's a miracle really that
our treatments work as well as they do
in these in these very different people
so what we're trying to do with FMR
is figure out whether we can identify
clusters of patients that have similar
biological problems as indexed by fMRI
and and which can be used to map
functional connections in the brain and
and if so then maybe we can then maybe
we can target specific treatments to
individual people who are most likely to
benefit from them and can you find
different patterns yeah so we found
Ella's emphasize I don't think this is
the the best or final solution to this
problem but it's it's a it's it's one
solution that works well we found we can
identify four very different patterns of
of abnormal functional connectivity in
the brains of different depressed people
we can assign individual people to those
categories based just on their brain
skin and then those those categories
predict different kinds of symptoms and
a different likelihood of responding to
transcranial magnetic stimulation which
is a brain stimulation based treatment
that you could imagine it I mean it's on
a much coarser scale but the goal is the
same as with optogenetics where you're
trying to stimulate a particular circuit
to to modify the activity of that
circuit TMS works in much the same way
and it's and it's much more effective in
one of these subtypes than in then and
the others and you think if you look for
those patterns in mice you can find out
for Tony if mice are depressed yeah
we're we're working on that one thing I
think that's that's really nice about
the mice is that you can you know
Elizabeth talked about this the one of
the limits of fMRI is it's fundamentally
kind of correlational in nature you you
observe this change in in the brain scan
and and it seems to correlate with a
particular behavior or symptom but there
are many changes in these brain scans
and it's really hard to pinpoint which
one if any is causally related to
particular behaviors and mice afford us
that that opportunity so that's that's
one thing we're trying to do in the
brains of our of our mice so because we
want a little bit of time for questions
but so kind of for one final thought for
anyone here so looking down the road
five ten years down the road what's your
wish list or what's your vision
of where you think we're gonna be or
what do you think is gonna be the next
what we're what are we gonna do to
unlock this and take it the next step
and what are what are we gonna be
talking about a decade from now well I
can tell you what we're trying to do I
laid it out it's the rosetta brain I
think being able to understand behavior
all the way through from the the
behavior to the neural activity to the
actual wiring diagram for me as sort of
the Holy Grail - to reduce it's not even
reduced it's to provide the foundation I
went into neuroscience because I wanted
to understand how three pounds of stuff
gives everything that we see hear and
feel and it just seemed incredibly
mysterious to me and after being a
neuroscientist for several decades it
remains just as mysterious I don't think
we're any closer to limit no sadly we
but we I mean the core question why does
it how does it why are we conscious how
do we how does it feel how is it that we
feel the way we do I don't think we're
any closer to understanding and I sat
there thinking about it for a long time
and decided that thinking about it
wasn't gonna get us anywhere further but
I'm hoping that if we actually see an
example where we can go all the way from
the neural activity to the through the
behavior to the circuitry it'll at least
provide us a way of maybe formulating
the the right next question which I
currently don't have my my PhD adviser
was Christoph call who has spent most of
his career trying to understand
consciousness and I think and now he
he's the scientific director at the
Allen Institute where their goals are
very similar to the goals of the people
here which is to tease apart the
circuitry of a mouse and so I my my
feeling is that although the the
circuitry of a mouse is clearly
different from the circuitry of a human
basically the building blocks are
already there by the time you get to the
cortex
if you look at a piece of Mouse cortex
and you change the scale bar and you put
it next to a piece of human cortex they
are indistinguishable so the basic
building blocks we think even you a
you're smiling because you're a nursery
but you will not be able to tell the
difference if I change the scale bar
even the neuroanatomists at the Allen
Institute were fooled by this this pair
of pictures so I think that you know we
we as as humans evolved in the last
couple hundred thousand maybe million
years as primates over the last couple
million I mean most of the work was done
I think by the time we evolved as
mammals we split off from mice 7080
million years ago the basic building
blocks I think are there for us to
understand and once we get those then I
think we're off to the races to figure
out what makes us human but I would be I
would be pretty happy if we could get an
understanding of what makes us mammal so
we want to leave a little bit of time to
questions we've got two microphones
going around so if you have a question
please wait till somebody brings you a
microphone thank you very much to the
panel
you've given a really great overview of
some of the genetic and biochemical
techniques that have advanced the field
in the last decade or so but can you
talk more to some of the informatics
techniques that might be advancing the
field you mentioned and a math for
dimensionality reduction there have been
issues with you know fMRI specifically
with sort of the kernels and statistics
that are going on there but how has you
know big data a data science machine
learning also influence the field thank
you well I'll just say that I started
off in machine learning and neural
networks as a grad student and I think
that those that field has affected and
in two ways first of all it inspires us
how to think about how the brain works
trying to build something is one of the
best ways of figuring out how something
works beyond that in the last couple
years machine learning techniques have
transformed big data in neuroscience
just like they've they're transforming
it in all other in many other fields so
that our
ability I mean we're now collecting huge
datasets in you know either calcium
imaging or connectivity and you know you
can't you can't just stare at it anymore
it's the same question of you machine
learning approaches provide ways of
generating hypotheses again just just
like knowing the connectivity and then
it takes a real brain at least so far
we're not quite out of business yet but
the these these big data techniques
transform have are in the process of
transforming how we sort of generate the
scientific hypotheses that then we can
go out and test that at least for me
that's one of the big ways I would say
coming back again to the other point is
we need computer scientists and people
who understand code and and and big data
to understand the brain right because it
is a computer right and and I again the
insights you get from people who who
know that are really critical what's
really fascinating we've got Amazon and
Google and and all of those big
companies now really interested in brain
research they're hiring our graduate
students right you this deep learning
these algorithms I mean the whole thing
is coming together so so I think both
fields are now really stimulating each
other and I think you know that's gonna
be a path towards getting where we need
to go part of the difficulty is to
understand actually the behaviors and
the behaviors that turned out to the
machine can do a better job than humans
in order to determine how many forms of
a behaviour that they are actually bob
data and hover they're creating there's
a syllabus of the behaviors and they're
trying to find a neural correlates to
that would you turned out you know you
actually finding exactly the neural
correlates into the syllables of the
behaviors which as a human server you
could have completely missing it so I
think that's kind of how does the two
things our neuroscience enemy machine
learning aspects are really assisting
each other
another question depressed lab animals
produced developed isolated do you alter
the genetics howdy how do you produce a
depressed yeah I can take that one the
real challenge
you mentioned like the like animal
models of mouse models of schizophrenia
autism we have a much better handle on
the genetics of some psychiatric
disorders like schizophrenia and autism
than we do for depression what we know
about depression is it's it's it's
heritable if your mom is depressed
you're much more likely to grow up to be
depressed yourself and that's not just
about environments but it's probably the
results of the shared impact of many
many genes each having a very small
influence on your likelihood of becoming
depression and that interacting with
your experience so that makes it a lot
harder to have like a genetically based
model of depression that they just don't
exist yet they may one day I'll push
back on that a little there's uh there's
a model of learned one model of
depression as a model of called learned
helplessness and there was a guy who
bred generation after generation rats
that showed this this trait of learned
helplessness and over the last I think
it took him a good 15 20 years to breed
these unfortunately he started doing
this when rats
seemed like they were going to be the
right model system not mice but he read
he bred these rats that were genetically
distinct and showed this trait of
learned helplessness and they and he and
others have gone on to dissect some of
the circuitry that is disrupted in these
and identified the lateral habenula
particularly important circuit in this
now that's one particular type of
depression but I think it just shows how
the the kinds of behaviors that we have
can actually often be modeled in a row
analogous I'll also add to that to say
that you can even study things like
confidence in a rat or a mouse it's not
obvious that something like confidence
which feels like it's an internal state
would have a neural correlate but one of
my colleagues at Cold Spring Harbor is
identified a brain region in particular
types of nerve
that seemed to encode an animal's
confidence and confidences for example
one of the things that can be easily
disrupted in in depression so I think
that when you actually really think hard
about how to probe the behavior in a way
that traditionally people who work on
rats and mice have not but are now
starting to you can actually sort of get
more traction on these things than you
might have thought the sort of
ridiculous notion of you know a
depressed mouse or rat becomes less
ridiculous so another question thank you
for the presentation you talked a little
bit about the advance how these advances
impact the diagnosis of mental disorders
how do you see on the practical level
what do you see these advances such as
optic genetics or anything else that you
talked about here how do you see them
advancing the treatment like what can we
expect in the next couple of years with
things like ECT or kind of anything that
I might not even be able to understand
from your answer to this thank you I
think getting back to the the
transcranial magnetic stimulation thing
as one example of a treatment that's
based on stimulating a brain region ECT
electroconvulsive therapy is is our most
effective by far treatment for
depression and it's basically a big jolt
that is to the brain that's very
stimulating to everywhere in the brain
right and and and yet it also has a lot
of undesirable side-effects and so we
reserve it for the people who are most
who most need it who don't respond well
to other treatments I think one
potentially exciting Avenue in future
would be figuring out whether there are
particular more focal brain areas that
require a particular kind of stimulation
you could even imagine maybe a little
further down the road cell type-specific
stimulation getting at what a lot of
Tony's work was describing the overall
goal being more precision in the way
where we're stimulating brain regions
might lead to more effective anti
depressed
responses and fewer side-effects and I
think that's a vision that everyone kind
of shares so unfortunately we are
running out of time we really need to
thank these amazing scientists for being
here
you
[Music]